.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW IS JOSÉ CASTILLO
WHO IS CURRENTLY A RESORT DUTY
MANAGER AT THE WALT DISNEY
COMPANY.
JOSÉ, ARE YOU CONCERNED, FIRST
AND FOREMOST, ABOUT YOUR JOB,
YOUR JOB SECURITY, BY SPEAKING
OUT HERE TONIGHT?
>> HI, LAURA, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME ON THE SHOW.
HONESTLY, NO, IT'S NO SECRET
HERE IN CENTRAL FLORIDA THAT I'M
RUNNING FOR CONGRESS AND I'M A
DISNEY WORKER AND A STRONG
CONSERVATIVE.
TO BE HONEST I'M NOT CONCERNED
ABOUT BY JOB BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
I THINK IF I WERE TO GET FIRED
FOR MY VIEWS, I THINK IT WOULD
SEND A WRONG MESSAGE TO
CONSERVATIVES, YOU KNOW, THAT
CONSERVATIVES WOULD NOT BE
WELCOMED AT DISNEY.
I KNOW THAT, YOU KNOW, RIGHT
NOW, IT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S A
MISCONCEPTION.
THIS IS WHAT I TELL PEOPLE.
THERE'S A MISCONCEPTION OUT
THERE THAT EVERYONE AT DISNEY IS
RAGING LIBERALS AND THAT COULD
NOT BE FARTHER FROM THE TRUTH.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE OR A
CANDIDATE RUNNING FOR CONGRESS I
HAVE TONS OF PEOPLE THAT WORK AT
WORLD DISNEY COMPANY THAT REACH
OUT TO ME DAILY ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
>> Laura: JOSÉ THIS IS ABOUT THE
CURRENT STORY.
I'M GLAD YOU'RE HAPPY AT DISNEY
BUT AFTER PEOPLE SAW WHAT THEY
SAW ARE NOT HAPPY AT ALL.
I'M GLAD YOUR JOB SECURITY'S
THERE, GOOD FOR YOU.
BUT SOMEONE WHO'S A TRADITIONAL
SOCIAL CONSERVATIVE, SERIOUS
CHRISTIAN OR FRANKLY ANY OTHER
FAITH IS NOW BEING TOLD THAT
DISNEY'S PURPOSES, POLITICAL
PURPOSE, IS TO ENSURE THAT
KINDERGARTENERS TO THIRD GRADE
ARE TAUGHT ABOUT SEXUAL
ORIENTATION.
THAT IS THE HILL THAT DISNEY
WANTS TO DIE ON AFTER MAKING
BILLIONS OFF OF FAMILIES WHO ARE
TRADITIONALISTS.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM HERE.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> I THINK THEY'RE MAKING A
TERRIBLE MISCALCULATION THAT
ULTIMATELY MAY BE BAD FOR
BUSINESS.
THEIR STATEMENT SAYS THIS ABOUT
THE BILL THAT RON DeSANTIS
PASSED.
THEY SAID OUR GOAL FOR THE
COMPANY IS THE LAW TO BE
REPEALED BY THE LEDGE STRAIGHT
TOWER OR STRUCK DOWN BY THE
COURT.
ON THE LEFT THEY TALK ABOUT
DEMOCRACY, AFTER THIS ELECTION.
I SAID WHAT ABOUT OUR DEMOCRACY
RIGHT NOW?
YOU KNOW, THE PEOPLE OF FLORIDA,
A LOT OF DISNEY CAST MEMBERS
VOTED FOR OUR STATE LEGISLATURE.
INTO IS ARE DULY ELECTED MEMBERS
OF FLORIDA, HOUSE
REPRESENTATIVES IN THE FLORIDA
STATE WHO PASSED THIS BILL SENT
IT TO THE GOVERNOR AND THANK GOD
OUR GOVERNOR HAS THE BACKBONE TO
STAND UP TO COMPANIES LIKE MINE,
DISNEY, AND PASS THIS BILL AND
STAND WITH THE PEOPLE OF
FLORIDA, STAND WITH THE PARENTS
AND PROTECT OUR CHILDREN.
>> Laura: WELL, I CAN'T TELL YOU
HOW MANY PEOPLE I HEARD FROM
TODAY SAID THEY'RE NEVER GOING
TO WALT DISNEY WORLD AGAIN.
HER NOT GOING TO DISNEY WORLD,
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DISNEYLAND,
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO SPEND THE
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS THAT
THEY'RE CHARGING AT THE STAR
WARS EXPERIENCE AT DISNEY TO
ESSENTIALLY BE TOLD THEY'RE A
BUNCH OF, YOU KNOW, ANTI LGBT
HORRIBLE AWFUL ROTTEN PEOPLE.
THEY'RE JUST NOT GOING TO DO
THAT.
SO I GUESS DISNEY CAN GET THEIR
INCOME FROM NON-TRADITIONAL
INCOMES BUT THAT'S A HEAVY LIFT.
A NEW POLL SAYS MAJORITY OF
DEMOCRATS SUPPORT THE NEW
PARENTAL RIGHTS BILL.
SO DEMOCRATS SUPPORT THE
THE NUMBERS ARE HUGE.
AGAIN, DISNEY GOING WITH THE FAR
LEFT EXTREMISTS, WHICH, I CAN'T
IMAGINE WHAT WALT DISNEY WOULD
THINK TODAY.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THE REASON
THAT'S HAPPENING IS BECAUSE,
REALLY, THERE'S THIS SAYING,
SQUEAKY WHEEL GETS THE AGREES
AND THE SMALL MINORITY IN THE
DISNEY COMPANY PA PART OF THE
LGBT COMMUNITY ARE BEING THE
LOUDEST AND MOST VOCAL.
SO WE NEED CONSERVATIVES HERE,
ME, I'M A CAN'T DATE BEING AS
LOUD AS I CAN TELLING PEOPLE WE
NEED TO STAND FOR OUR
CONSERVATIVE VALUES AND I'LL DO
THE SAME IN CONGRESS.
BUT WHAT DISNEY HAS TO REALIZE
ON HE-WE'VE GOTTEN E-MAILS WITH
THEIR STANCE ON THE BILLS BUT
WHAT PEOPLE FAIL TO REALIZE I
KNEW WHERE THEY STOOD ALREADY.
>> Laura: BUT WHY WOULD YOU WANT
TO WORK AT A COMPANY WHERE THE
COMPANY ESSENTIALLY THINKS THAT
YOU'RE A BIGOT?
I MEAN, WHAT THEY SAID
ESSENTIALLY ABOUT RON DeSANTIS,
AND ALL THE ACCOUNT A VISITS WHO
SUPPORT WHATTED DISNEY DID, WAS
THAT RON DeSANTIS WAS A BIGOT.
SO, I MEAN, AGAIN, THE MESSAGE
TO TRADITIONAL AMERICANS IS
YOU'RE NOT WELCOME HERE.
THAT'S THE MESSAGE DISNEY IS
SENDING OUT.
I'M GOING TO SAY IT VERY CLEARLY
TONIGHT.
EVERYONE'S WALKING AROUND THIS
ISSUE.
THEY DO NOT THINK THAT
TRADITIONAL AMERICANS SHOULD
HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE OR,
FRANKLY, BE ON CORPORATE BOARDS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
CONSERVATIVES ARE ON THE BOARD
OF DISNEY TODAY, WE SHOULD HAVE
PUT THEIR NAMES UP ON TELEVISION
TONIGHT.
BUT I THINK THIS IS JUST THE TIP
OF THE ICEBERG AND CORPORATE
AMERICA IS GOING T